So health care, in the U.S. anyway, is clearly
more of a sick care system then a health care
system. We wait until people get quite ill
then we try to pull them back.. And we need
to change our focus towards prevention. Some
og the underprivileged are leading the human
genome project. I think we have something
to offer here because the study of genetic
variations that play a role in disease risk
is happening all around us. It's a day luge
of information. And that should provide the
opportunity to practice prevention much more
effectively because it should be done as an
individual activity instead of a generic one
size fits all. So my hope would be, in this
health care reform that we're getting in to,
we will focus more on prevention to try and
reduce health care cost, and we will empower
people to have information about themselves
that is actionable, that they can use in a
fashion that's not so generic but specific
with them to focus on staying healthy. And
that might be by knowing what your risks were,
and then adjusting, diet, exercise, medical
surveillance, all of those things. To do what's
right for you, might not be right for the
next guy, but it's right for you and have
a chance at living a long life without chronic
illnesses or premature terrible things like
cancer or heart disease or stroke. And that's
a big picture but I think if we invests ourselves
in research and policy decisions we ought
to be able to get there.